i introduced him as one of the tech
masterminds behind this symposium well
he still is elia brodsky is one of the
co-founders of pine biotech and serves
as ceo
his background is in applied mathematics
and data science and currently
completing a degree in business and
management from tulane but you haven't
been working on that this week but
before i pass the mic to him i want to
remind you one more time to make sure
you register at
omnicslogic.com for your free learning
portal and as soon as elia comes on the
screen i'll post that link one more time
just in case and again that's a free
sign up so go at it so back to the
matter at hand mr broski oversees the
strategic development of research
projects and manages the team
responsible for biomat informatics
analysis training collaborations for
biotech and a big part of the symposium
so ladies and gentlemen let's kick off
with elia it's all yours
thank you grant and thank you to all the
speakers before me
i'm also gonna share my screen
and um i will speak um a little bit uh
on
why we are here today
you know what is the goal of actually
bringing together the whole community
and i hope to
kind of connect the different parts of
this symposium and in general the
symposium really represents what we do
throughout the whole year even though
the symposium only happens twice a year
so first of all
let me tell you a little bit more about
what we do and how what we do
fits in with what we see
as a community consensus about
bioinformatics training and kind of the
current challenges and gaps and what
currently exists
so
uh one of the challenges i i think we
just heard from dr casulis mentioned how
different universities different
networks different branches of the same
network can have very different opinions
about what bioinformatics training and
needs are and i think that there are
ways to
work more efficiently and faster
outside of that framework of academic
institutions to really address these
challenges at scale right because that's
one of the
problems here is that bioinformatics
degrees data science degrees they tend
to be really narrowly focused
on this
unique combination of engineering and
biological skills or biomedical skills
and therefore exclude the majority of
the students that are just not exposed
to the domain and are not able to
appreciate the way that this skill set
fits into their future research
so
another component here is that
bioinformatics training is really not a
single track not only is it a very
dynamic kind of a field where all the
time you have new methods new skills new
types of data it is also something that
varies across many different domains so
for example if you're learning oncology
as opposed to applying bioinformatics
and infectious diseases maybe the types
of skills that you're expected to have
very
as as you advance in those fields right
in the beginning they might look very
similar but as you advance
those types of databases
methods uh maybe specific types of
questions that you need to be able to
answer they start to be very very
different
and
that's why
we kind of arrived at this set of uh
fundamental principles that guide our
armix logic program and that includes uh
being able to combine several of these
essential elements into a training
experience and those are the courseworks
uh practical activities and case studies
and projects
which really i i hope that you were able
to
experience in these
couple of sessions that we had over the
past two days
course work of course relates to
just traditional elements modules if you
will that kind of take a particular
topic data type or a question and break
down how that topic could be um
understood mastered or even just kind of
applied in a specific way
practical activities you know a lot of
moops online uh training uh coursework
exist out there you know you can watch
lectures you can learn about fascinating
topics but really you get to experience
the component of problem solving and
challenge uh kind of addressing
different challenges that arise from
data when you start working on things
with your own data sets and in your own
kind of a project so
practical activities that we have
include building pipelines and
understanding the logic of
bioinformatics pipelines but also a lot
of coding in both python and r to really
understand how to clean data wrangle
data prepared for analysis visualize
your data and also apply different
statistical and machine learning
techniques either specific to the domain
of bioinformatics or really in a more
generic way
and finally this component of case
studies i think is very important
because as i mentioned these domains
vary as you get more and more deep into
the project and so we've been working to
source high quality curated data sets
from publications that have an impact in
a particular field or domain and prepare
them as case studies that are open-ended
so you get started as a tutorial and at
the end you can kind of use that data
set in many different ways so it
introduces you to the topic gets you
into the topic deep enough for you to
understand the context but still the
ending is open
and
another i think challenge
is to really have clear objectives and
outcomes that are measurable and so the
way that uh we do it is we
uh try to address this question of what
do students need to know for them to get
started right and i think that's a
different question
from what did they need to know to
master a particular topic
because
the majority of the students
are not going to pursue a full degree in
bioinformatics
and they're not going to specialize with
those bioinformatics skills to address a
specific topic i think what's more
reasonable to expect is for them to be
familiar with the way bioinformatics is
used in various domains and then to
determine whether they will participate
as a user as an algorithm developer as a
technician
or potentially a person who is involved
in the conversation right and so because
of this uh dynamic technology and
software and tools that are being
developed
uh
this is an important aspect to just
introduce them to this field i think
early on
now another topic that we already heard
throughout this whole symposium as well
is that you know bottom line you have to
be allowed to not only play with kind of
small demo data sets but actually work
with larger data sets and that requires
uh processing power for large data sets
and effectiveness of how your code is
organized and maybe help from a
technical
team that can prepare your pipeline for
those larger data sets so
that's why we are kind of focused on
collaboration with academic and industry
partners to make sure that those tools
are available as well
and i think finally in other challenges
with faculty right because
uh you know when we speak about
introducing bioinformatics at a an
earlier stage that means that the
faculty have to be comfortable
introducing those topics at an earlier
stage to answer questions to maybe uh
you know guide and monitor progress of
students evaluate them and i think
that's another set of challenges that
really we would like to
you know find a solution for because
it is extremely difficult i think in
some areas to attract
faculty who are trained and well versed
in the domain of data science and
bioinformatics and you know ultimately
having to deal with a variety of topics
you know that they might not be prepared
to do
so this is kind of like our operational
uh motto which is
sos standardization organization is
systematization right so how can we take
uh fragmented curricula about
bioinformatics applications in many
different domains
find a way to agree on what all of them
need to
cover
and organize them in such a way that
they could be systematized and
implemented in basically any place from
top universities
to universities that maybe are liberal
arts and not exposed too much to the
area of data science and
biomedical research in general
and another aspect of that is really
bringing it earlier on in this journey
of a student so that they can master and
embrace the
terminology and the kind of thinking
behind data obviously mastering skills
as they go along
and as they choose the specific
direction and focus
of their own journey and path
i think what's helpful in the context of
uh organizing and kind of structuring
these things is bloom's taxonomy of
learning where we kind of see from
basic to more advanced how the learning
actually happens and then start to
introduce that
into
what we call training in bioinformatics
and that means
from kind of knowing terminology knowing
uh specific details and elements of what
bioinformatics is like genomics you know
how do you know what genes and mutations
are
to eventually uh kind of growing in your
ability to
analyze you know use tools and
algorithms and techniques and eventually
becoming creative
and and and that's why we kind of
organized our resources in such a way
that anyone for free can register on our
portal and start the learning process
and then develop
skills that they would need and a logic
behind the analysis that they really
need
to potentially become experts or just
become
you know aware of these topics and and
being able to try them at least before
they commit to a long-term and demanding
path to mastering bioinformatics and
data science skills in full
now with the help of organizations like
national association of idea principal
investigators as well as many other
collaborators that we work with be it
academic or industry experts we have
developed this core
set of topics that we cover in our
training and that includes an
introduction a very high level
introduction to bioinformatics and
different omics data types
deeper into different specific
types of data that are commonly used
like genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and then more
technically into the area of coding and
specific statistical and machine
learning algorithms that we kind of put
under the umbrella of data science
beyond that we also have divided the
areas of our training into the domains
of our oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture now i
realized that that might not cover every
possible application of omix as we heard
even today in beauty wellness in space
uh in other domains but nevertheless
it's a framework for us to kind of start
expanding from the basic
set of skills into more specialized and
as we are able to
build relationships and kind of find
areas of mutual interest we hope to
further expand the number of
specialization tracks and expand the
number of project examples and experts
that can lead those specialization
tracks across the board
excuse me
so
one of the i think important parts
of working with complex data is being
able to
utilize complex algorithms
without knowing how to overcome
technical challenges with coding and so
we offer both
coding and no coding paths to mastering
bioinformatics and i think that is a
prerequisite really for biologists to be
able to get started we have quite a
number of good examples of
individuals that came from a life
sciences and clinical background that
are able to leverage such tools to get
started and eventually that builds
enough momentum for them to take on a
more technical skill that they see as a
as a necessary requirement for what they
want to do
and doesn't kind of introduce this
feeling of oh i have to do a full degree
in engineering now that i have already
maybe multiple degrees in life sciences
to just even get started right i think
it kind of helps push them over the
board over the that first threshold and
gives them momentum to keep going
um i think that you know
again this is more about uh kind of
making sure that you're addressing a set
of outcomes as you are planning these
kinds of degrees but i think this is
very important for uh you know planning
and and uh developing a strategy for
effective implementation right when we
come to
outcomes and measuring those outcomes we
have to have a very good sense of what
that is in the short term as well as in
the long term
and i think that what we have discovered
for our participants is that
you know this is a very long term
process
someone might get introduced to a
specific project in the summer and then
have the time and availability to take a
full course in the winter or maybe
complete it the next summer and so
that's why we have focused on kind of a
profile that you build over time and
building that profile includes
a technical measurement like gaining
points for completing coursework or
practice exercises
as well as more of an open-ended
portfolio that you can start building
from you know connecting your portfolio
on linkedin let's say connecting your
publications on
work id
developing independent research projects
and being highlighted for those projects
winning prizes or presenting them at
different conferences so really that's
where we hope that students that
participate in such training can build
out their personal profile
having that as a place that they can
also share and apply for opportunities
in research as well as industry
positions and so
we we kind of have these tools for
tracking progress with points as i
mentioned research assessments where we
bring mentors to evaluate
the
efforts and the projects that students
prepare and then bringing together life
and data sciences what we mean by that
is really trying to expand beyond a
narrow focus of bioinformatics skill
sets to be able to talk about actual
uh biological questions or biomedical
questions that are being answered in the
context of mentorship and projects
and i think today was an excellent way
to kind of uh see that in practice right
all of the different projects that we
saw that got the prizes but also we have
a full page on learn omixlogic.com where
students have
already submitted tens of projects that
they have completed either individually
or in teams
from around the world from places like
louisiana state university georgetown
university amity university in india and
universities in ghana so we really have
this international representation of
different teams and projects that have
been completed by students working
through these this kind of training
now as grant already mentioned several
times
this is free
to get started um and really affordable
i hope
across the world
to get into we offer very low fees for a
basic subscription and i think very
affordable fees for specialized training
but you can start for free so i do
encourage all of you to if you don't
have an account yet go to learn
omixlogic.com
forward slash sign up and now there you
can sign up and create a profile now
another resource is our group on
linkedin
where we post regularly job
opportunities and opportunities to learn
from experts in this field so you can
join there and also learn about those
build your connection and make sure that
you know people know about you as well
now briefly let's talk about this
symposium and what we have done
over the past couple of days
we still have a few speakers that are
going to present today but yesterday we
heard about this need for bioinformatics
training and research in india and in
africa
had an excellent discussion about i
think what we really see is that
local efforts are almost as equally as
important as international uh right and
so
instead of trying to say that you know
this is one center that will do
everything for everyone really what it
is is there's a community that needs to
share and exchange opinions and kind of
best practices to be able to build
natural locations where this kind of
training can happen
and also we heard about the need to
actually go and translate
those early efforts and training into
translational research where data from
data scientists or maybe students or
citizen scientists can be analyzed
locally so
indian
challenges are maybe different from
african challenges different from
challenges in the us right and so
building out that community and pool of
talent locally is critical
for those communities and so we heard
quite a few successful programs that are
being developed in those regions
and we hope that our regional teams in
africa and in india and south america
could be
part of that effort as well
now we also
heard about the india partnership
program quite a number of universities
that have signed up to that which means
that they will contribute their content
and benefit from the uh type of
resources that we make available
and that includes some of these great
universities like amit university and
others um there
we also heard today
uh and yesterday from great speakers
from both louisiana state university or
louisiana biomedical research network
from international locations uh like dr
joseph borg
uh interesting applications of uh new
technologies like single cell um from
sweden um and we heard about the t
biometric platform from the tauber
bioinformatics research center so it
really was exciting to see how these
different locations are offering
interesting insights into different
applications of bioinformatics
and we heard today
and we saw just kind of give evaluation
to student projects which are starting
to follow the lead of these experts
right so we saw projects in space in
oncology uh different applications to
different kinds of biomedical areas of
biomedical and basic research and i
think that was really exciting to see
that we actually see this translation of
ideas from you know such presentation as
this
um where an expert speaks about what
they're doing and then students being
able to pick up on that fine project or
data sets and kind of develop their own
independent projects so i think that is
really a validation and a path forward
for us to move uh further into um kind
of building out this international
community so
another component that we announced was
the listing of jobs and opportunities
for internships that you can find
remotely
in your area or by moving to a new
location so we have this new page that
will continue to grow and expand job
listing on a portal and we will link it
to your profile so that you can actually
showcase your skills
your effort and your project examples
that you've completed to be able to be
more successful at applying to those
positions
i think these events
kind of bring together an international
community so it was really exciting to
see
these projects that got
highlighted as the best ones by
independent judges that didn't even know
about
each other
in some cases but
they have agreed
on the best technical and research
project altogether on a competitive
topic
the most innovative approach in an
established domain
and a promising research direction for
future potential and
knowing these individuals some of them
and interacting with them i've really
seen their growth both in in technical
ways but also in conceptually that they
were able to
not only follow somebody's tutorial and
somebody's guidance but also start
bringing new ideas not from you know
just being creative and kind of thinking
about something but from analyzing data
so really data-driven research projects
that came from
students who are you know basically not
very experienced yet but have been able
to uh do this nevertheless so really
exciting to see that
another component that you know we don't
talk too much about but i think industry
participation right so we heard a little
bit about that but we also heard about
um interesting opportunities for
students that master data science and
bioinformatics to um be innovative and
provide practical solutions to real
challenging problems so for example in
our last symposium we heard from
individuals that work in bioinformatics
at the therapeutic companies like cam 4
or companies that are developing
infrastructure for bioinformatics and
for teaching bioinformatics like google
or we
we had hosted panel discussions and and
experts from the faba academy that talk
about industry perspectives on
bioinformatics and biotechnology in
general so i think that's another very
important component to what we're doing
because ultimately there's not a place
in academia for everyone to succeed in
the long term and i think that knowing
about those opportunities outside and
also for companies to know that talent
is being developed and is growing um
that is also an important agenda for
what we do
uh we uh
we will talk a little bit more uh in our
next slide about the significance of uh
taking
uh bioinformatics uh
training further to address these two
important needs and and that is the
diverse types of data that continue and
develop
we heard today about nanopore we heard
yesterday about 10x genomics
probably recently most of us have been
paying attention to ultima genomics and
the price of sequencing going
dramatically down
that
leads into the need for i think a
broader framework for analysis
integration modeling and visualization
of different types of data and so that
is a recurring topic and challenge that
i think we will see being addressed in
the future and for us what that means is
that we really need to focus on
making that continuous workflow from raw
data to interpretable biological
insights that can integrate effectively
across these different
technologies and so i was really happy
to see
uh you know dr julia panoff and uh also
uh elizabeth taranenko who uh
showed advances on the t binding for
platform that we also offer as a tool in
the training that we offer and as a
commercial solution for our research
partners but that is really exciting to
see that you know this solution exists
and continues to evolve and develop to
address these important needs uh in
single cell
or in the future in uh multi-atomic
integration and user-friendly
monotonomics integration as well
uh just a brief reminder of what we
heard yesterday we heard about machine
learning and multi-ominous integration
in the area of single cell research from
dr nikolai oskolkov from sweden
we heard about interdisciplinary
forensic sciences integration of vitamix
technologies in forensics
and i thought that was really
interesting from dr sarah zappico we
also talked about
networks
and graph theory in application to
databases for patients in oncology
and we heard about precision medicine in
pediatric oncology and the way
bioinformatics is informing state of the
art
in uh new emerging places like brazil so
really fascinating uh set of topics that
i hope we can use to turn into another
set of case studies
and and kind of leverage these
connections to offer students
opportunities to explore these topics in
much greater depth than what we heard um
there
now we also heard today
about solutions in
medical informatics which obviously is
kind of the other side of the coin when
we talk about bioinformatics and omix
technologies it's really about how to
integrate them in many cases into that
clinical workflow so we heard about
predictive analytics clustering time
series analysis classification and
others and i hope that those topics are
really
uh you know something that ultimately
converges because omix technologies can
inform um a lot of those questions as
well another presentation that was
really exciting for me to hear is the
presentation about the cpgr
bioinformatics
kind of network or
this effort in south africa where we see
them being able to both train support
research but also include services into
their
kind of mod model uh so that they are
successful um you know at addressing
industry and academic needs so really
great presentation there
and finally you know maybe one of my
favorites
was bioinformatics in the beauty
industry from dr raya heinen who uh
talked about her company but also in
general the need and interest in
developing
new
targeted personalized solutions for
wellness and specifically for beauty and
i think that you know that's that
that's a component that aligns well with
what dr castoulis mentioned about
entrepreneurship ultimately states can
invest you know government funding and
research funding into research projects
so getting more grants but there's also
a component of innovation in
entrepreneurship that exists and i think
that's
a way to translate these ideas and
innovation and skills out of highly
specialized and qualified students into
this industry domain so and as a result
of you know partially this presentation
but also our internal planning
we are going to host a bioinformatics
hackathon focused on omics wellness
and uh
also health so we are going to make
available some uh publicly available
data sets that have been curated
we will make tools available for
specific types of analysis related to
this domain and we will work with our
academic and industry partners to
organize this hackathon in november so
november 17 to 22
this year we will host this hackathon
and then we will present the results of
this hackathon at a later date but the
ultimate product uh here will be
that each individual will be able to
join a team
build an actual application
and then publish and share that
application that we will host for one
year with our industry partners so that
anyone can try and use that and and you
see that as an mvp as a prototype for
some practical use case in the omnics
wellness and health domain
so
um with that um i also want to mention
that right after this symposium our team
is actually going to continue working on
expanding our code or no code
bioinformatics paths in the omixlogic
portal and we are excited
to be able to um you know bring this
across
the network that we heard about today
the national association of idea
principal investigators and work with
those partners to make sure that it is
more accessible and effective
throughout the whole network and because
of these efforts and because of you know
gradual progress that we are making with
these relationships uh it is really
exciting to be uh now um you know seeing
the results of this effort across the
network so we recently shared this uh
update we have individuals from a
university of hawaii
university of nebraska
delaware and others that have graduated
from this training um so really um i
think it's over a hundred people that
have gone through this training from
across the
network and we are now
also going to announce new
research fellowship opportunities for
students that have basic skills that
would like to work over the next few
months on developing independent
research projects leveraging
bioinformatics and leveraging their
skills
that they will be able to use
um and finally my last slide you know we
are excited to be selected as the
finalists the semi-finalists sorry for
the ed tech cup uh in new york uh the
largest egg tech accelerator in the u.s
so uh we will be sharing more
information about this in the coming
days and we hope that you will support
us in that uh journey as well so again
thank you and uh with that i will leave
some time for questions
great thanks again elia uh you did
mention interest in dr cannon's work is
that due to need in the beauty area i
just thought i'd ask it never mind
so we wanted to get to some uh
questions here's one from the chat and
this is a long one so we'll go here it
seems that omics logic is all about
medicine health etc it seems other
domains are less targeted till now
please could you lead me where to find
omix related
to the fisheries aquaculture domain
environmental dna
etc and then or
how can we use the omnilogics platform
to bring improvements to the domains
that i just mentioned
yeah excellent question so i think one
of our challenges is actually finding a
long-term relationship around those
topics and significant interest in those
topics for people to be able to kind of
you know fully develop and leverage
those um resources so we do have people
that have worked on fishery um
and environmental projects we just don't
have enough volume to turn those into
actual um kind of specialization tracks
so
yes you can still use bioinformatics and
omix logic provides resources to be able
to do that
and also yes we would love to work with
others who are you know experts in those
domains to prepare those specialization
tracks and i hope to see that just over
the next few months actually because we
have worked on those uh briefly over the
summer
seems like uh omix is touching literally
everything it's it's such a great pre
post suffix as it were
so what are some of the specific
objective objectives taken for
development promotion and improvement of
data centric research experienced by
omixlogic
well one of the major objectives for us
is to allow students to go even further
so right now we're kind of at the stage
where a student can develop their
project and talk about it right share it
what we would love to do is take it
further by showing that they can
actually develop solutions with those
skills and by that i mentioned the
hackathon that would be one of the first
steps in that direction is to allow them
to build applications that other people
can use leveraging these efforts that
they have you know analyze data created
a model maybe created a database or
something like that so really create a
platform for applications and then as we
develop that i think that will lead into
the next phase where we will offer
support to research projects or to even
um you know innovative entrepreneurial
ideas to take that further as well
okay
what are the bioinformatics skills that
the omixlogic research and training
program offered intend to enhance
well like i mentioned we want to provide
a universal education about
bioinformatics but i think there's a lot
of effort in that domain already
we want to provide specialized skills
that are data science you know coding
data management data wrangling data
visualization things like that but i
think what is important is that within
that broad umbrella of skills
is also the integration with biology or
life sciences skills
application in this domain
and soft skills right being to being
able to think critically um you know
come up with innovative solutions
communicate your results things like
that right so so that's really why our
program i think is different is because
we we put that emphasis on logic and
developing logic based on data and also
providing opportunities for them to
interact speak and describe their
projects as well
cool i got one more for you if we can
keep it under 60 seconds i'm going to
challenge you how can the student and
research community benefit from the
training provided by the omnilogics
programs platform to gain research
experience
i think the best way is to find a mentor
we have a network of mentors and develop
an independent research project so the
research fellowship is really the best
program for that
great eli it was great to hear about all
these updates and it looks like we have
an exciting path ahead we hope that
after the event we get to further
discuss the way all of these
international efforts can be coordinated
for the benefit of all the students and
young researchers that are learning and
applying data science and biomedical
research so thank you so much